welcome to this video yeah this is a new
part new episode of the view I games
reviewed reviewed yeah I keep getting
feedback that I'm mispronouncing that
but okay what can you do let's see we
have a second game here then i'm going
to show you our viewer as the white
player here jatta root koski from poland
he some now rated 1400 as it is also
apparent in the in the text year 1400
but at the time that game was played and
his the black player he has also rated
1400 at the time he was not rated at all
he's some not a very experienced player
but he played a really really good game
here and this is the game that even
submitted yeah we going to have a look
he starts out with a for our viewer and
black player here who I decided to not
named mean he's not knowing about this
so why not I mean just keep it anonymous
he played the eloquence defense this is
an opening that is not seen very often
on on any level yeah the top level
basically never played and there are
some specialists here on amateur level
or intermediate level play that um very
often it is an opening that annoys the
white player it's nothing that you get
very often you kind of don't know what
to do um in any case it's not an opening
where why it should despair it's
something that you should welcome
because normally white gets a pretty
good game by easy means in the game here
chocolate chooses a very simple
continuation he just played the move d3
to cover this pawn and to be honest
about the only move that I told like in
the game that he's playing very early on
it's not that this is terribly bad it
covers the pawn but it's just not very
and white can play e5 against this
opening and you really should even if
you don't know it well it's still the
move that you should play it's so it's
also relatively easy to to play because
and what you just do is you put those
pawns in the center and here the easiest
way to play is just to take on d6 after
any recapture white is just going to
develop by normal means yeah Knight to
c3 a knight to f3 the only move that you
maybe should be aware of that it is
often a good idea to play the move h3
yet to get this Bishop g4 possibility
out of the picture other than that it's
just very straightforward development ya
like like this let's say yeah played
this move and then you go here or here
and then you cancel and why it has a
nice center and it is easy to play
you're not really facing any any big
problems the other recapture this here
White has a very nice setup that is
useful to remember where you play this
Bishop e3 Roxy 1 and the idea is that
whenever plague black plays 'if I've you
have the opportunity to take take and
play see 5 gaining lots of space on the
queenside that's all you need to know to
better this opening really up to a very
decent level let's say 2000 level I mean
that's all you need to know not really
not really much more and it's a it gives
you a decent game with chances for an
advantage ok d3 as mentioned it's not a
mistake it just doesn't try to do
something really against the snide f6
move now black has a relatively easy
game if he plays it right but well he
doesn't really but we will see black
plays d5 this is good of course yeah you
put upon in the center the tech White's
pawn on e4 another good move here is of
course 'if I've yeah gaining space and
yeah this can easily look like Russian
defends the petrol of the White has
played III
those moves our good but defy this is
fine certainly yeah now your puter crazy
five attacking the night after all so he
wasn't afraid really to advance at all
he just delayed it for one move however
when we push the pawn to e5 in almost
any given situation we want support for
this pawn and very often you need a pawn
support you cannot let's let's put this
on the board black plays the normal move
97 this is attacked and you want to
support this pawn on e5 and very often
it is just just necessary and the useful
thing to have the pawn on d4 here to
cover this e 5 pawn reliably so the move
d3 is something that is kind of
superfluous in this situation you rather
want the pawn or define we would see in
the game that he plays the move d 3d
form in relatively short order if he put
a plate d for now black mean it's not
forced to but like could even play the
movie 6 which kind of looks like a
french defence wear white has used two
moves to play d3 to deform yeah if the
night would be on c3 or d2 already it
would be a french but this move is
missing due to white having lost the
tempo very often you want the pawn
supporting e5 yeah each replay tonight
f3 though which is not bad and black
played e6 that's not a bad move however
he sort of gives up on the idea to put
his bishop out of the pawn chain on the
other hand if you want to put it out of
the paunch and you would have to move
the night on g7 again but it was a
possible idea let's say you could have
also started with c 596 and maybe put
the night here to put the bishop out
finally to f5 or g form however e6 is
not a mistake as mentioned it's a
playable option e 6 and now white went
Bishop to g5 yeah developing this bishop
and asking black okay what are you going
to do about your take on the Queen
Bishop e7 or F
six the only moves that keep material on
the board black played the move f6 this
is playable it's not bad but it is a
choice that involves some risk because
you're weakening your central structure
a little bit and you're also weakening
your e 5 square we would see after the
capture black took like now has a
weakness only five now this is an
unprotected square it's not controlled
by any of the parts and also it cannot
be controlled anymore by upon so this
will always be the duty of a piece to
sort of Tikal is this square the
alternative for black was Bishop e7 and
this is the move that that I would have
preferred yes black simply keeping the
structure sound wide will probably take
and ta has to take into account that
black maybe his putting this putting
this threat into the game queen before
check winning the b2 pond so wide will
probably do something about it let's say
c3 and after let's say c5 white will
probably go deform and we have a French
candle structure where white has lost
the temple with d3 d4 but it's still
it's still it's it equal it's an equal
position black is a bit suffering from
this Bishop but it's not so terrible he
has chances to sometimes get it out with
b6 Bishop a 6 or still f6 later the move
f 6 30 plane in the game it's not bad as
mentioned but it is relatively early you
can sometimes delay it and to up to them
may be more proper moment yeah why took
night takes and the move deform that's
important yeah it's kind of yeah you
don't really want to move the pawn twice
but it has to be done so you have to in
a way a middle admit a little bit okay
it's better than that's a good move it
prevent it prepares Bishop d3 of course
where you want to put the bishop this is
the best square it's important to think
of a set up and go for it the West white
set up here is d4 bishop on d3
yeah this is by far the most active way
to play this if you after Knight f6 just
think okay I want to develop okay let's
play Bishop e2 yeah you're developing
and you're preparing castling but this
doesn't serve a purpose on e2 is just a
relatively passively plays Bishop it's
better to play it like in the game yeah
put this on before where it belongs
controlling e5 and preparing to put the
bishop on the best possible Squared's
quality yeah not not quantity you can
play quicker yeah yeah like visually two
castles but then you don't have the
pieces on good squares you rather invest
this move d 4 and then put it where it
belongs yeah an interesting moment now
this is an in fact the first key moment
of this game not a decisive one but it
shows that what black is doing here he
placed the move h6 you know black is
attacking this Bishop and in this way
and wins a little bit of time because
white really does not want to take on f6
if Y takes him he gives up the bishop
pair and the Queen on f6 is even having
some influence over the year 5 square
yeah after let's say here here on Knight
to c6 see fifl that's cannibals and then
the queen is actually helping to cover
the weakness on you find this is why why
does not really want to take them you
played Bishop H form the problem with
this age six movies it's a very let's
say short it's very short term thing
that it gains it gains us a check on the
bishop the bishop retreats and then you
have to take stock did h6 help me or not
and in this case we can relatively
quickly see it did weaken something they
age six move we can the g six square
normally this light square is very weak
especially considering that there is not
even a pea
that control would say I mean
theoretically speaking if there is a
bishop on h7 let's say this is a
different matter this Bishop would cover
this weakness but the bishop is home on
c8 g 6 is a completely week square if
you just imagine the Queen hitting there
or bishop or night it's very very
problematic and the benefit is
relatively little you have this short
term attack on the bishop which why do
of course yeah tick tick off and you
really haven't gained a lot sometimes
you want to play h6 in some situations
to gain this little cubby hole for the
king however the Kings on g8 so that you
cannot get back rang mated but you're
already the F poorness move and it's
mostly the weakness that counts so this
is something that black will come to
regret he played Bishop e7 now now that
is an ok move um i would also think of
but especially well here it's already a
bit tricky with age 6 being played if we
go back a moment here i would also think
of this kind of development c5 attacking
white center and trying to put knight c6
and bishop d6 yeah this is a setup that
will come to my mind yeah bit more
ambitious but it's more active you want
to control if I haven't make sure that
while it's not installing a long-term
peace there this is in fact a plan that
is more appropriate without age six if
we look at this each six here if you
want to invest this kind of time with
with c5 you're getting hit with this
move which isn't a problem with the pawn
back on h7 but here Bishop g6 is a very
problematic move yeah this shows that
the move aged six is not really helping
black he went Bishop e7 probably also
for the reason that after Bishop n85 was
played but let's say after Bishop b3 now
black ken castle and make sure that the
bishop is not coming not coming to g6
with a with a check spoiling the
castling rights however the white player
here went Knight e5
instead of Bishop d3 that is also a good
move it looks at this weakness very
important and it also addresses the idea
of c-5 if black now would play c5 what
can take and all of a sudden check pay a
very very unwelcome with it with the
grid yeah why does winning here
immediately at least in exchange yeah
here you can think of this happen
putting the King out of out of ya back
from the back rank it's very very danger
there or you can simply plug the
exchange if you like so Bishop f6 is a
big threat yeah this is something that
black absolutely has to take care of so
what should he play there's a very clear
answer to that like he had really only
one decent move he had to castle and
note that again this is not helping him
yeah this weakens it would be much
better to have the pawn back on h7 in
this situation here why probably will
play I mean he can do this but it's not
so clear that it helps but white will
probably just continuous development and
we go from there this is still a decent
position as mentioned i don't like age
six but it's not that black is losing
here or anything however he m he saw
this idea and he decided to fight it
with another move he played the move g5
yeah this is some really a big mistake
to play g5 him and what black did not do
here he did not really asked himself the
question okay where am I going to put my
king whoever by King find a safe place
yeah with all those pawn moves know what
you had those pawn moves the King does
not have a pawn shelter anymore and the
only cover that he has is um yeah other
pieces that surround him so it's not
that he's getting checkmated in like
five moves but he would become under
huge attack
and he has an interesting moment
actually he played Bishop g3 our viewer
and it's a good move you also have to
ask yourself can you punish this
directly a move trying to punish this
directly was Queen D free that's a move
to think about threatens mate twin g6
check King f8 Queen f7 made however what
you need to think of still is what is
black to black place the move he has to
play route g8 yeah covering this and
then we have to take care about the
bishop again we don't have a checkmate
yeah so we have to play Bishop d3 and
now if you think of it you could have
played Bishop g3 immediately and not
insert queen d 3 root g8 you can ask
yourself have I gained from the move
Queen d3 is the Queen well positioned
there one it is not terrible to have it
there wouldn't you rather want the
bishop they're getting out on d3 and
maybe the Queen jumping in this
direction yeah it's actually a case
where the short-term thread the the
thread on g6 is tempting but the queen
is not so well positioned there I think
that the move Bishop g3 is just better
it has to be played we cannot play with
the piece sacrifice so put it there and
the intention is to use the bishop to
invade on the light squares black plate
night bd7 now now that does make some
sense developing this piece and fighting
45 yeah and now again a move I like
Bishop d3 completing development yeah
not completing but continuing to develop
the bishop is on its best diagonal and
it intends to invade their own g6 just
very strong move another good new fear
was H for this also came very much into
consideration whenever they go age 6 g 5
or a 6 b 5 on the other side of the
board you have to consider the move h4a
for in the other
on the other side of the board simply
because it's a tool to get your rook
into play from the initial position you
don't need to castle then anymore yeah
the rook is doing something here trying
to open up the aged father this is also
strong move both was was good we'll see
that in the game Bishop d3 yeah now
black was very much concerned about them
Bishop g6 idea and correctly so this was
a big threat um he had a choice him yeah
he needed to do something about it and
he decided to play night to f8 covering
this square it was probably a little bit
tougher to take on e5 but it's it's not
fun yeah Black is on a huge pressure and
it is not easy at all to give him some
advice after the capture it's
interesting here white can take with the
pawn and get this in or you can take
with the bishop and keep this put this
on a strong on a strong square that's
actually debatable what's better I think
both moves are pretty good this is the
more short short term centered move
let's say where you are very much
tempted by this check well this keeps
this bishop on a very strong post both
would have been good night at 80 ever
was played and here we come to the move
that are already suggested earlier age
for using the rook on the initial on the
initial spot castling would be a mistake
here yeah it's really it's not the way
to punish black to the fullest h4
develops the rook yeah this is a
developing move yeah like it's under
huge trouble h2 x g5 is a threat you
played rukka g8 and now we see that with
them I capture our rook has gained
access to this open age file very nicely
played
yeah right now had a wide choice of
attractive moves but here the white
player piatto route off route kofsky I'm
sorry he chose a very straightforward
approach and this is something that is
very often rewarded in chelsea yeah just
play with a purpose and follow up on
this idea that you have he played rook
age 6 yeah the idea is rook takes f6
Bishop takes f6 and queen age 5 check
here's song he has so on he saw that the
Queen on age 5 in combination with the
night is deadly so he tries to make this
idea work that's very nicely played yeah
following up on this concept on this
plan and black really doesn't have much
that he can do he has to play this move
blocking this diagonal otherwise what I
mean almost without any exception would
be able to take on f6 and get this
chicken now we come to them the most
interesting moment of this game actually
um and yeah here it's it's very what the
white player plate now here our viewer
is really a fantastic idea I believe
very M yeah I would be very proud of him
if he would come up that with that idea
if it was my student because it's highly
original it's a really original solution
it was not if this was would be the only
winning move it would be really a touch
of genius but I'm here white can almost
with any move maintain a very very big
advantage so white can also play a non
fancy move let's say with not like 93 or
Queenie to and be much better this is
probably I say what I would go from just
put out the this is peace Queen out and
long castles to get all pieces and
attack
this is strong but the solution played
by by a sea otter he is really really
excellent very original he played the
move King to eat too and it's very
difficult and it's very difficult at
first 2022 yeah what is the idea of them
and that it is really great he was
thinking okay I want the Queen to h5
this is the the square I want to deliver
the deadly check so I'm going for it
Queen to h1 Queen to h5 after the
sacrifice on f6 this was his idea and
this is a really great idea King it to
to get this going and it is just the
case where you could argue that this is
a little bit too complicated yeah I can
also just develop and be very very much
okay probably winning but it is strong
and a very original solution like it
really has no defense to that idea yeah
Queen to h1 take on f6 queen age 5 it's
just great yeah he played the move
Knight to you for and yeah here it comes
threatening yeah this isn't business
probably going to be a maid yeah it's
really no no way to defend Black now has
to do something about this check he went
Ruby g5 I can also take on g3 first but
it doesn't make a whole lot of a
difference 93 yep getting getting the
last pieces out and black now played
Bishop I have six it was a bit tougher
to take on g3 it puts up more resistance
but ultimately yeah after this white
will get in this check yeah the idea
that she was putting his his hopes on
with with King II to Queen edge one
white will be able to realize at the end
with winning effect is very nice yeah
bishop f6 was played takes
eggs yeah and night takes very nice now
we are walking those black played this
yeah and now here White has more than
one way to win the game but he found a
nice one took with the rook rook
captures check and the check finally
yeah that was the big idea that he
played for King e7 and Bishop h4 what a
fantastic Pena Black has has no way no
way out him absolutely no way out he
went night to age 7 and now yellow white
has more than one move to win but
checkmate if you can meet the guy you
really should do it made ends the game
yeah very nice quick win here for our
viewer and it really played a good game
i am the only as mentioned the only move
that I'm not really liking this is very
early t3 in the opening which is kind of
passive but he did not play passively
afterwards that's very important yeah um
he was probably intimidated by this
opening that he may be never faced
before and yeah kind of decided let's
play a safe move first but he didn't
play passively afterwards but he played
all them if we go back do a quick and
recap he played all the aggressive moves
that you needed to play d4 is important
to get to them all important d 3 square
and here you played the aggressive move
95 Bishop t3h floor this is how you want
to play a play with the purpose and get
your attack ian if you can get active
and attack the guy you really should do
that so very nicely played and yeah then
we came to this really nice move King
YouTube with this highly original idea
to get the Queen to the key square very
nicely played yeah you can only argue
that it is unnecessarily complicated but
very very nice so this was the second
installment
of them of the viewer games reviewed I
hope you enjoyed it this was a little
bit quicker than the game before but if
the games are longer and have much
content the video is going to be as long
as it needs to be not going to rush
things it's about learning things and if
it takes a little bit of time to get all
points and then so be it yeah okay well
thanks for watching and well the series
will continue thanks